Cameras aren't working.
It's getting super frustrating.
This is what it's like
on "Life Below Zero."
Cameras already down.
Tough conditions all
around to film in.
No heat.
No power.
No anything.
Won't even turn on.
I've fallen too many times.
We have bad winds.
It's just a typical
day on the Arctic.
Making best with what we got.
Takes a lot of food to feed a
bunch of people for a few weeks
out in the wilderness to make
the show while we're out there.
We're getting ready
for a winter move off.
And the place we want
to go is to the Kiwalik.
We go down there, sometimes
for several months at a time,
and we hunt, fish, and gather.
It's worth the challenge.
It's worth the dangers.
It's worth the time.
And the unknown doesn't bother
me because nobody knows.
Today we're loading up
our entire show in order
to follow the hailstones to
Kiwalik for some adventures
out there.
And part of what
we have to do is
load everything that we need for
a couple of weeks in the field.
One sled with most
of the camera gear.
Personal camping gear here.
Another sled that's mostly food.
A bunch of propane.
A generator.
We use a tremendous
number of camera batteries
on a daily basis, so we
have to run a generator
when we're out in remote areas.
I always carry this
safety bag that's
got our communication devices.
It let's us keep in touch
with our office in Anchorage
and L.A. And then also it's
got emergency provisions,
medical kit, and
emergency shelter,
warm clothes, and
food, and fire,
and everything you would need
if you are stuck somewhere.
Pretty excited to go.
Hailstones are almost
ready to leave.
So we're going to
start up the machines
and haul them out to Kiwalik.
[music playing]
So we're carrying this
big load out to Kiwalik.
We were going over these
really hard-packed wind drifts,
and it's pushed up the gate.
It's bent the gate
the wrong direction
on two of these hitches now.
So we're kind of in a bit
of a sticky place here.
See, this thing's at an angle.
Yeah.
There it is.
OK now, see if you can get
this-- yeah, there you go.
- There it is.
- Yeah.
Hallelujah.
One, two, three.
[engine reving]
Just another day
on "Life Below Zero."
So we're here in Kiwalik.
We finally made it.
This is a bit of a
victory celebration
going on at 3:00 AM.
110 miles over some
really rough terrain,
across tundra and frozen
Bering Sea, and got here.
Pretty much just had to
make hard luck shelter
and get some food into the crew.
We've got everything that we
need for the next month with us
in these four sleds.
Roll out our sleeping
bags and get some rest.
And then wake up in
the morning and build
our little tent city here.
Everyone's pretty
excited to be here.
This is what it takes
to follow the Hailstones
into the middle of nowhere.
Woo hoo.